[Music]
a very good morning and afternoon to
everyone here virtually welcome to
today's webinar
liquid array next generation
multiplexing for routine clinical
microbiology
i'm christina jewel of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by broker microbiology and
diagnostics to learn more about our
sponsor please visit brooker.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
may have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and simply click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
i would now like to welcome our speaker
dr jennifer dugan head of business unit
syndromic liquidase broker
dr dugan you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction and
thanks for joining the webinar today uh
my name's jennifer duggan and i'm head
of the business unit here at brooker
microbiology and diagnostics for our
syndromic liquid arrays
and i'm delighted today to be
introducing liquid array to you our next
generation multiplexing technology and
its applications
in routine clinical microbiology
so today i will start by giving a very
brief introduction to the molecular
diagnostics business area within
mcbrooker microbiology and diagnostics
and i'll then
introduce liquid array and talk you
through how it works um
and what the diagnostic approaches are
with the technology and then move on to
some examples of the clinical
applications that we already have
available for mycobacteria syndromic
panels for sexually transmitted
infections and gastrointestinal
infections
so broken microbiology and diagnostics
is now a rather broad division obviously
originally with bringing the moldy
biotyper to clinical microbiology and
for routine microbial identification
brooker have since expanded in this area
to offer solutions to the lab for
antimicrobial susceptibility testing
and microbial strain typing with our
infrared biotyper and along with our
molecular diagnostic solutions and most
recently with our liquid array syndromic
panels that i will tell you more about
today and for all of our developments we
really aim to keep the patient in focus
by bringing technologies to the lab so
that you can turn around your lab result
results in a faster and more
cost-effective way
so molecular diagnostics here at brooker
and the products that we offer actually
started quite some time ago um
back even in the in the 90s with high in
life sciences developing the genotype
assays that work with pcr on a strip and
then evolving throughout the years to
develop
real-time pcrs and in 2018 were acquired
by brooker and then together we brought
the innovation of liquid array into the
market in 2019
and then this year launching liquid
array with applications for syndromic
panels
so our full portfolio of solutions
includes extraction systems
extraction chemistry
detection systems
and
ivd assays across a broad range of
clinical areas that you can see here
ranging from mycobacteria all the way to
human genetics
an example here of their flu recycler xt
and the validated assays that run on
that show the breadth of the portfolio
that we already have available on that
instrument and this is really a high
performance thermal cycler that i will
talk more about today that does not only
real-time pcr and melting curve analysis
but also powers our liquid array assays
so what is liquid array
well
it's a next generation multiplexing
pcr-based technology
it provides comprehensive coverage for
infectious disease diagnostics and it
does it in a familiar pcr-based workflow
i said it's only possible with the
unique features of our high performance
fluid recycler xt and i'll come on later
to talk about them in more detail and
how it is that they support the liquid
array technology
and all of our assays running liquid
array are automatically interpreted and
are provided with results at a glance
bringing then next generation
multiplexing for infectious disease
diagnostics really to the routine
clinical microbiology laboratory
i'll now talk about
what actually
happens when we're running a liquidase
and how it delivers next generation
multiplexing
so as said it's a pcr-based technology
and we're using linear after exponential
pcr with lights on and lights off probes
it's underpinned by the features of the
fluid recycler xt and by that i mean the
well to well thermal precision of the
instrument as well as the outstanding
optical alignment
and using the integrated software at
fluid software xt we're able to provide
results at a glance
so looking at this in a little bit more
detail the linear after exponential pcrs
and asymmetric excess pcr with limiting
and excess primers
so looking at a
target
strand of dna here
doing normal pcr cycles after multiple
cycles of course we all know that you
generate many many copies of um pcr
products but we also here have a limited
primer meaning that um after the
exponential phase we're generating a
single stranded pcr product and that
really drives high sensitivity by the
generation of this single-stranded dna
looking more closely then at the pcr
product and how it is that we go about
detecting that
we're using lights on and lights off
probes
so
using our lights on probe we have a
fluorophore and a quencher and and this
i'm sure will be familiar to many of you
that when the fluid four and quencher
are kept far apart such as when the
probe is bound to a target piece of dna
the fluorophore is able to fluoresce and
be detected by an instrument
whereas when the fluorophore when the
probe is sorry
not on the target strand of dna uh then
the fluorophore and quencher come closer
together and and you no longer would see
that fluorescence
our lights off probe has a quencher only
and i'll show how this
works in practice
at low temperature we would expect no
fluorescence with the lights on and
lights off probes designed to bind to
the target
adjacent to one another so the lights on
probe is
directly next to a lights off probe the
fluorescence is quenched and so
therefore no fluorescence is detected
as we increase the temperature we expect
fluorescence to be detected the lights
off probe is designed to be released
from the target at a specific
temperature
so when this happens of course we can
then see fluorescence
from the lights on probe
as we raise the temperature further
we would
see fluorescence switching off as the
lights on probe has been released from
the target and
you no longer see fluorescence
of course we design our probes such that
these
binding and release events happen at
predictable temperatures and you then
are able to see
fluorescence against temperature and and
interrogate the different probes at
different
temperatures
so we have a temperature dependent
multiplex detection within each optical
channel
i said this is only possible on the
fluid recycler xt because of that well
to well thermal precision because we're
really looking at multiple
binding events in the one fluorescence
channel across different temperature
steps we need to have very highly
accurate and precise um
temperatures reached within the wells
and we can achieve that with the flu
recycler xt
we also in the instrument have
outstanding optical alignment so not
only can we multiplex within one optical
channel by using temperature uh we're
also able to multiplex in a more
traditional way across the optical
channels and in our case um the optical
alignment means that there is no
crosstalk and we require no color
compensation so we're giving multiplex
detection across those five optical
channels with no crosstalk
and as you might have seen
you of course then can generate these
rather unique fluorescent signatures and
so it's really important that we bring
this to the routine lab with the
integrated fluid software to provide
then results at a glance you will see uh
the the fluorescent signatures produced
in the report but it's not required for
you to interpret them that's done um
already by the integrated software
giving an unambiguous report
automated results interpreted and
machine learning algorithm providing
results at a glance
so we apply this technology in a couple
of different ways
and in the first example here um for
multiplex pathogen detection
we can probe multiple different pathogen
sequences using lights on probes um each
of them of course with a with a
different melting temperature uh so that
we in the same optical channel can
detect multiple different pathogen
sequences
and we can also apply it to multiplex
detection within a region or regions of
a single target so that's where
again with different melting
temperatures we're able to multiply
probe a single sequence with the lights
on and lights off probes
with multiplex detection using multiple
probes within a single target
and i'll show that in a little bit more
detail
so here we have
a target um strand of single-stranded
dna and and showing here the the um
lights on and lights off probes um that
have bound to that
so as we apply an increase in
temperature we can we can watch what
happens with the probes and also i
encourage you to keep an eye over here
on this um fluorescence against
temperature
plot
so
as the lights off probes
are desorbed uh you get an increase in
fluorescence as the lights on probe
switches on
and we see this happen across the the
region that we are looking to detect
then as we increase the temperature
further the lights on probes now um come
off of the target and we see then
reductions in the fluorescence that we
are detecting
and this is all done in a predictable
order on the basis of how we have
designed those probes so we know the
temperature that they will desorb from
the from the single stranded um from the
single stranded target
now if we were to have a mutation in the
target sequence the
within this probe region
um the melting temperature of that probe
would change
and as such the fluorescence signature
would also change and you can see quite
clearly then that you could identify the
difference of a wild type from a
mutation
so with liquid array we are really able
to target multiple targets per optical
channel
we generate these unique fluorescent
signatures
we have high resolution between the
fluorescent signatures and we can use up
to five optical channels with no
crosstalk between them
so this multiplexing within each channel
plus the multiplexing across the five
optical channels is what really delivers
the next generation multiplexing that we
see with liquid array
we offer multiple workflows depending on
the clinical application and that would
range from manual extraction um
our smaller extraction system that that
extracts 12 samples in a run to our
semi-automated genome extract flex t
system which can process up to 96
samples and set up your pcr plate
then the assays are run on the flu
recycler xt and as said the integrated
software provides results at a glance
so looking then at the applications here
for within mycobacteria and resistance
detection and differentiation
so
um as an introduction tuberculosis
is a disease caused by mycobacterium
tuberculosis it's an infectious disease
with a tremendous public health impact
with approximately 10 million new cases
per year
and around 500 000 cases of drug
resistant tb worldwide
and there's also non-tuberculous
mycobacteria so these are
environmental bacteria that can cause
disease and the incidence of
non-tuberculus bacterias are increasing
worldwide with treatment of ntm disease
dependent on the species and also
detection of ntm
to the species level it can improve can
provide an important clinical and
epidemiological information
so there are two um questions i guess
clinical questions in the mycobacteria
space that
that we're looking to answer here
so fluid type mtbdr 2.0 is powered by
liquid array and it provides detection
of the mycobacterium tuberculosis
complex and its resistances to
riftampazin and isoniazid from patient
specimens or culture
and detects up to 45 different mutations
in the mycobacterium tuberculosis
complex and is who endorsed
so here you can see um quite clearly
from the the report that we would see
from liquid array that yes there are
fluorescent signatures there and the
reporting will tell you whether the mtb
complex has been detected it will tell
you the mutations that have been
detected and whether actually the the
organism is um whether the sample is
showing my bacteria that is uh sensitive
or resistant to the to the drug in
question and we're covering up to 45
mutations in the mtb complex in a single
well which is something normally only
achieved with sequencing
for fluid type mycobacteria and we are
detecting and differentiating 32
clinically relevant non-tuberculosis
mycobacteria and detecting the
mycobacterium tuberculosis complex in
one well from positive culture
so again here really the power of liquid
arrays is shown you can detect at 32 of
these
ntms and the mtb complex and
mycobacterium genus in a single well
and this is just here showing the range
of ntms that we're covering um with this
assay
and again the flu recycler xt report
that you would receive after having done
your run
unambiguously tells you which
ntm has been detected
by the by the assay
so with these liquid array essays
brooker's expanding the comprehensive
portfolio that we already have for
mycobacteria testing to include this
first-line resistance testing of 45
mutations in a single well um
which is which is being achieved by the
liquid array technology
and we have a second line resistance
assay with liquid array mtb xdr
coming in 2023
and we have our assay providing uh
differentiation of these 32 different
ntms in a single will
with fluidite mycobacteria
in all cases the fluorescent signatures
are fully interpreted by the integrated
software providing you results at glance
and so we're really delivering a
workflow that's compatible with routine
testing with reflex testing from the
same isolate possible so from the same
dna isolate you can test for mtb and
your multi drug resistance as well as um
the second line resistance or that the
second line resistance assay coming soon
and also the geno extract um
isolate is suitable for sequencing if
that's something that you also need to
do for um other research purposes or or
doing some epidemiological studies
in terms of liquid array for our
syndromic panels i'm introducing here
our syndromic panel for sexually
transmitted infections
so stis are caused by a broad range of
different bacterial viral and parasitic
pathogens the top two most common
bacterial pathogens in europe uh being
chlamydia trachomatis and niceria
gonorrhea of course
trichomonas vaginalis and mycoplasma
genitalium are also recognized as
important and under recognized causes of
sti
and in 2020 who estimated
374 million new infections with one of
the four stis chlamydia gonorrhea
syphilis and trichomonas
and it's really important that we are
detecting stis untreated these pathogens
can lead to
many complications from chronic pelvic
inflammation through pregnancy
complications and infertility vaginitis
cervicitis and urethritis and often um
they they may be being carried without
without symptoms um and so it's really
important that we are identifying people
who are carrying these
um and also to be able to provide the
correct treatment in cases as well
so fluorotype sti detects seven
prevalent bacterial and parasitic sti
pathogens in one well that includes dual
target detection of chlamydia
trachematis and niceria gonorrhea and
were validated from urine and genital
swabs
so we've developed this as a syndromic
panel for routine testing covering the
four most prevalent pathogens plus three
potentially pathogenic species as well
it's a qualitative test and as said the
sample materials validated are for urine
genital and genital swabs endocervical
vaginal cervical and urethral
so we have a dual gene target strategy
for both chlamydia trachomatis and
niceria gonorrhea
the two targets for chlamydia
trachematis ensure that we have full
coverage across a cryptic plasma and
genomic strains but only one target is
needed to get a positive result so if
you detect one or the other target
sequence you will
you would get a positive result
whereas the two gene targets for niceria
gonorrhea are serving to increase our
confidence that we can report with a
niceria gonorrhea positive because of
the frequency of gene recombination
between niceria species it's really
important that we have a stringent test
that if you have a positive result you
can be confident that it is niceria
gonorrhea and so for that reason we
require both of these regions in the
port a and the opa genes to be positive
in order to report a niceria gonorrhea
positive so that you can have confidence
in that result
a single positive would report for
nycedia species
here's an example report um of what you
would see using the flurotype sti assay
and again you can see here an example
where two genes of niceria gonorrhea are
detected and we're reporting niceria
gonorrhea positivity
and in this example a single nyseria
gonorrhea is a gene is our niceria gene
is detected and here we're reporting
nicerious species
the additional organisms mycoplasma
hominis hominins uraplasma parvum and
uria plasma ureoliticum are commensal
organisms and so we do report these out
but the results for these species should
be clinically interpreted in the context
of patient presentation and then the
absence of other causative pathogens
the fluorotype sti is currently
validated on our geno extract system
onto the fluid recycler xt and providing
results at glance with the fluores
software and it will be available soon
also on the geno extract flex tr larger
um
liquid handling system
showing some results from our
performance evaluation studies you can
see here really very excellent
sensitivities and specificities and very
low rates of invalid results that we're
seeing at these results shown for
genital swabs and then here um for urine
samples again very low rates of invalid
results from testing urine samples
and also a low number of indeterminate
milk curves
the performance evaluator for fluidity
psti and it gave the following quote
that based on the performance in their
laboratory the use of fluid type sdi to
detect sexually transmitted pathogens in
the daily routine of a service of
microbiology is highly recommended
and i think really that comes down to
the confidence in niceria gonorrhea
reporting achievable through the dual
gene target detection
um the great analytical and clinical
performance and the workflow is
compatible with daily routine and the
ease of um
of
achieving those results at a glance with
the integrated software
looking now our next syndromic panel
that was just launched this summer for
gastrointestinal infections
um so gastroenteritis of course um is an
inflammation of the lining of the
stomach intestines and we know
characterized by diarrhea or vomiting
and there's many causes it can be bacter
viral bacterial parasitic
uh
can cause life-threatening diseases
especially in children immuno-suppressed
people in the elderly and of course um
hear the incidence range
of diarrhea in children
in europe
most cases do resolve within days but
persistent of severe cases can of course
require hospitalization
and it's a major cause of hospital
admission and has a large economic
impact and traditional diagnostic
approaches including microscopy culture
and pcr are labor and and resource
intensive and
also take a certain amount of time to
get results back to the to the clinic as
well
um and there are usually there are
different workflows basically for
bacterial species parasites and viruses
and even for within different bacterial
species
the uk standards for microbiology
investigations from public health
england um indicate that the use of
multiplex panels
but testing by syndrome can simplify
routine service through rapidity the
reduced cost reductive on of unnecessary
antibiotic usage when compared with
single testing
and so we've developed liquid array
gastrointestinal to detect up to 26
pathogens that cause gastroenteritis in
two wells it's a single test for
bacteria bacterial toxins viruses and
parasites and we provide it in a
streamlined workflow from stool sample
to result
so obviously the bacteria viruses
parasites and pathogen-associated toxins
are all detected in a single protocol
and we're covering 26 of them across
these two wells with well one
um detecting the most prevalent
pathogens um so
here listed your your bacteria and
toxins
the viruses of norovirus and rotavirus
and your parasites
in well two we are reporting and
detecting the less frequently reported
pathogens again bacteria viruses and
parasites
this is validated on stool samples
you can see again
an example report here and with showing
the fluid software again providing these
results at a glance so yes you will see
um traces fluorescence traces in your
report so you will be able to see the
primary data however you will be given a
completely unambiguous report of what
organisms have been detected or for
example if if all were negative and also
an interpretation of your control's
validity
workflow for liquid array
gastrointestinal starts of course with
your with the stool sample uh which is
swabbed and taken into stool buffer and
then um
vortexed um
briefly centrifuged and then the the the
actual stool buffer sample is taken into
uh the geno extract flex t along with
the other reagents
and in in the genome extract flex t the
instrument will automatically extract uh
the samples and then set up your your
two assay piece true bell pcr
um the pcr plate is centrifuged it goes
into the fluid recycler xt and at the
end of that liquid array cycle you get
results at a glance with the software as
previously shown
showing here then um some results from
the performance evaluation
with the pcr one targets we see very
good um sensitivities and excellent
specificities um across these targets
and very low rates of invalid results
especially when you consider testing
from stool samples uh
not 0.2 for invalid results was really
very impressive our evaluator was very
happy with that
and looking at the less frequent um
pathogens in well two um you can see
here again really very good
sensitivities and specificities and low
rates again of these invalid results
this is really important of course for
when you are running high numbers of
stool testing
and looking to really optimize your
laboratory workflow
and to know that you would have
confidence in both specificity and also
lack of
invalid
results that can hamper other tests
so with liquid array gastrointestinal
we're providing comprehensive coverage
with 26 pathogens simultaneously
detected across this single protocol for
bacteria viruses parasites and
pathogen-associated toxins the two-well
format covering all of these pathogens
in only two wells means that we are
really compatible with that daily
routine testing
i speak to many customers who
have to test over many multiple wells
and multiple tests um with
their current
system and looking to bring that in
where they're only having to run to a
single protocol with two wells means
that they can meet the the needs of the
clinical partners that they're serving
and of course results at a glance
provided
as a summary then across our liquid
array assays we're providing
comprehensive coverage where labs can
replace multiple tests with one
providing workflow efficiencies and fast
results to the clinic
it's
performed in a familiar pcr based
workflow which is then easy to implement
in the routine laboratory and we're
providing infectious disease testing for
syndromic panels for gastrointestinal as
as you've seen in sexually transmitted
infections as well as mycobacteria and
resistance detection
and differentiation
um
shown also here that we've developed
this with compatible nucleic acid
extraction kits and workflows taking you
from patient sample to results
uh with very high quality
and obviously providing these results at
glance in a user-friendly report so that
you can report accurate results with
confidence and without any need for user
interpretation
so today i've shown you the power of
next generation multiplexing across our
portfolio with mycobacteria assays
achieving 45 different mutations
detected within one well with flutotype
mtbdr 2.0 and up to 32 different ntms
detected in one well with fluorotype
mycobacteria
our fluid type sti syndromic panel is
detecting seven pathogens in one well
and our liquid array gastrointestinal is
detecting up to 26 pathogens for
gastroenteritis across two wells in a
single workflow
we also have a liquid array in
development and respiratory
we're really then covering infectious
disease diagnostics with comprehensive
coverage per assay providing streamlined
pcr workflows for you with results at a
glance in order to really help increase
efficiencies in the routine clinical
microbiology laboratory
so with that i would like to thank you
for your attention and i'll open now for
any questions
thank you dr dugan for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience
if you have any questions you would like
to ask please do so now just use that
ask a question box located in the far
left of your screen and we will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for okay we already have some great
questions coming in
dr dugan let's start with this one
with the enhanced multiplexing
capability within the fluorescence
channel do you find that this has a
negative effect on specificity
um thanks christina um yeah it's
that's a good question um it's something
that i think
many people are concerned about when
they look at a multiplex test but it's
not what we've seen through our
performance evaluations so when we look
at the data the specificities that we're
seeing whether with our sti i say for
instance are in the range 95 to 100
percent
and looking at
gastrointestinal um
the the specificities they are
clinically tested are 98 to 100
so
we we don't see an a negative impact on
specificity
thank you and our next question
how do you deal with new resistances in
variance within your liquid array assays
yeah great another another good question
so so we do get asked this um i guess
this quite frequently so um basically we
keep a close eye on on the literature
and on surveillance programs um to keep
up to date with mutations as they emerge
and are reported um
as an example with the mt fluidotype
mtbdr assay
that that essay is probed extensively in
the region of the genes that typically
show mutations
and so
a new mutation in the probe region would
generate a different fluorescence
signature um the the software would
automatically determine that it was
something new
and and not expected not one of the
typical um or known mutations and it
would report as indeterminate
so we
welcome
interaction and collaboration with our
customers if they do see uh such cases
to to get in touch and work together
with our r d team um where we would look
to understand and where relevant
incorporate any such
strains and any such results
dr dugan do you plan to include or
produce a kit for an m genitalium
resistances
so microplasma genitalium resistance is
a topic that we are um
that we are looking at along with um
some other some other possibilities
around what will be next for our sdi
portfolio so it it's not something that
we have currently in the assay or
immediately in development but it is an
area that we are looking to as as we
look to expand um and grow our solutions
for the lab
you
now have you looked at additional sample
types with the sdi assay for example
rectal or throat swabs
yeah i mean depending on the the
population and that's being tested these
are these can be really very relevant
sample types currently our um as a as
shown today is is ibd for
urine and for genital swabs
we have tested with rectal swabs and
with throat swabs and we know that
that does
that the assay does work with those
sample types
and we would look to incorporate that
within the ibd at some point in the
future
dr duggan for the liquid array gastro
test with so many targets reported
do you see positivity in most samples
and
how does this relate to single pathogens
versus co-infections detected
yeah um another good question
similar i guess to the as well to the
the questions that we receive around
specificity so i think again there's
some concern that or or some assumption
that with so many parameters covered by
the liquid array gastrointestinal that
you would see basically positivity in
you know in all samples or something
like that it's not what we see in
practice um through the performance
evaluation studies where the samples
were tested as part of um
sort of a routine routine workflow we
saw positivity in 35
of those samples so 65 of samples were
were all clear all negative not positive
for any of the pathogens and of the um
the second part of that was um single
pathogens um compared with co-infections
so
of those 35 percent that are positive we
see we saw single pathogens in the
majority about 85 percent of the time
and co-infections about 15 of positive
samples which which is um significant in
that
you know obviously culture um often um
you know one one organism can out
compete another um and and so we may be
missing co-infections um or or we may
not even be the lab may not be testing
for those organisms at this time so it
does provide for it for a broader and
more comprehensive coverage with with
the lab running this
test thank you dr dugan and
we'll wrap with this final question
given the inhibitory nature of stool
samples fecal material what are the
typical
invalid rates
yeah so um
as as shown as shown earlier in the
presentation um
another concern around fecal material as
i think the the the questionnaire is
getting to is um you can often see quite
high numbers of invalid rates with with
other other tests our invalid rate was
around point two uh point two percent
point six percent for well one and well
two so we are really seeing um
very low levels of inhibition
and invalid results especially given
that we're that we're working with um
complex
sample medium
and dr dugan i'm going to squeeze in
another question here
how much training do you need to switch
to running liquid arrays
oh yeah that's a great question um so
basically if you can run pcr you can run
a liquid array i mean we've developed it
in such a way that um yes it's giving
you um next generation multiplexing
really advanced level results we're able
to deliver that but we do it in a way
that doesn't require um you know
any any special training beyond what you
would be used to using um
nor it's set up in a normal familiar
pcr-based workflow and doesn't require
you know expensive cartridges or or
anything like that so it's very reliable
very robust and very easy to use and
obviously again i know i've mentioned it
a few times but we give all of those um
you get all of those results with the
unique fluorescent signatures we're
getting a lot of power out of that
information but the user doesn't need to
take time to to learn that or to
interpret it themselves it's fully
interpreted in the system and and you're
provided the results unambiguously it
tells you what target was detected and
whether any targets were detected
whether your controls worked you know
that the whole thing is is fully
controlled
dr dugan thank you so much for your time
today and for your important research do
you have any final comments for our
audience
thanks christina no i would really just
like to thank those for joining today um
it's been an absolute pleasure to
introduce liquid array to you and i look
forward to
more
in the future where we are able to
highlight um further further
developments in this field
so thank you
and thank you again and we'd also like
to thank lab roots
and our sponsor broker microbiology and
diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i also want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
i want to remind you that any questions
that we didn't answer today or any of
those coming in during the on-demand
period they will be addressed by our
speaker via the contact information that
you provided at the time of registration
today's webcast can be viewed on demand
and laborats will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thank you for joining us and take care
bye
you